on CBS this morning Food & Wine magazine
unveils its third annual list of
restaurants of the year the list is
featured in the upcoming June issue it
names the ten best new places to eat in
the United States this year's winners
span across the country they include
here's looking at you in Los Angeles
tusks in Portland Oregon June's all day
in Austin Texas Texas and recent James
Beard Award winner la Lu cuckoo-cuckoo
in New York City all the restaurants
have been open since March 2016 Food &
Wine magazine editor-in-chief neelu
Muhammad is here good morning good
morning what an exciting list and boy
the food looks absolutely delicious I
can't believe you have a copy and your
night looks the u-two absolutely tell us
about the criteria for selecting these
top restaurants you know we log a lot of
miles we went to 20 cities over six
months to find these incredible ten
restaurants and what we were looking for
is a restaurant that is more than the
sum of its parts so a restaurant that
has that is your to say quoi just do you
a little more French um and that feels
special what's amazing about these
restaurants is that they've only been
open for a year but they already feel
like an essential part of the fabric of
their cities they're fun they're dynamic
they're a little bit more casual than
what we've come to expect and some of
them are even open all day long let's
talk about Turkey and the wolf I love
the name of that that's a New Orleans
where your person said after he named it
after taking just a few bites the chef
there says he likes to take fancy food
and make it silly so Mason Hara furred
actually wears rollerblades in the
restaurant so there's there's something
about the idea of taking fine dining
turning into something that is very
accessible to everyone that is so
compelling and so this is a sandwich
shop that's open all day you can have
incredibly sophisticated ingredients but
in the form of subs and rows and
sandwiches and the chef happens to be
wearing rollerblade you you even say
that you noticed a trend between more
casual dining than fine dining well I
think fine dining
look ku ku is the the outlier on the
list for fine dining but we are seeing
places that feel like you could just
kind of roll in there and still enjoy
incredible food why do you think that is
casual on chefs
finding that maybe they want to loosen
up a little bit we all want to feel a
little bit more relaxed but still not
give up on that amazing quality of food
and so both chefs and diners I think
have come to a place where it's great to
be able to eat out every single day of
the week and to have a relaxed
experience one of the things I noticed
that food good restaurants are happening
all around the country not just New York
and California it has never been a
better time to eat than it is right now
I am NOT we are so excited when we look
at this this is the third annual
restaurants of the year list it is more
compelling than ever it's more difficult
than ever to pick the ten but that's why
these really stood out I think you know
many people don't realize two
restaurants also give back a lot to the
community and you focus on one
specifically in Philadelphia the rooster
soup company I'm obsessed with this
restaurant Michael Solomonov has a bunch
of restaurants in Philadelphia in fact
just won a James Beard Award a couple of
days ago as for his incredible
restaurant but rooster soup gives back a
hundred percent of their profits to
charity they're affiliated with what's
amazing is start as a Kickstarter and so
that when they do incredible work with
actually using leftover food from other
restaurants ie they have a restaurant
called federal donuts and they use all
of the new Fried Chicken and donuts and
all the chicken backs and chicken necks
they use for the soup at rooster soup so
they are literally it's a zero waste
situation let's go back to the cuckoo
number one I just like the name of that
what does that mean it's a little bird
it's a little bird and what makes that
so great because I love fine dining so
Daniel Rose came is is a guy from
Chicago who moved to Paris opened two
amazing restaurants in Paris I know him
well yeah open the restaurant called
spring spring was phenomenally
successful in a nor'easter Navy which is
another one it's his follow up what mix
of foods are good so what is amazing as
he came to New York with the intention
of bringing back French fine-dining to
downtown New York and he has done an
amazing job what's incredible about it
is that it's breakfast lunch and dinner
it's incredibly sophisticated the room
is beautiful designed by Roman and
Williams and the food do you agree
Charlie Toulouse pretty good pretty good
yeah yeah comes out and says hello to
everybody I like
he's very you know and I think that
that's also great about these chefs
they're all very engaged they're very
entrepreneurial they're very dynamic and
they care as much about hospitality as
they do about being in the back in the
kitchen okay and a shout out to June's
all day in Austin Texas fantastic Wow
I like Austin thank you very much
enjoyed this issue going to thank you so
much and you can find out more about
these top new restaurants along with a
recipe from each one so just log on to
CBS this morning calm